bene benissimo sono poi i generi
salatissimi perdetevi ricordate che la
settimana scorsa ho provato a fare i
livelli che si chiamavano carne e
prestito ci sarebbero e per finirlo
beckham paradise flash match e poi
inferno che non ho idea però proviamo i
ragazzi sono molto impaurito perché gli
altri erano un casino se possono essere
sincero però vediamo se questi sono
altrettanto difficili no spero di no
vero già lo vedo che bello incasinato
soprattutto la musica che mi impegnata
proprio che questa è una porta ma che
schifo sono stili vece nel senso che
sono fanno ribrezzo nonché sono brutti
perché ho mangiato cinque minuti fa ok
perfetto non male il primo dicembre
ragazzi avete visto seconda che fa sto
bene non lavoro più sono arrivato fin
qua vi prego check point di scongiuro
dove c'è poi il quarto tempo che già
sogna solo per miracolo non ce la farò
zitti zitti zitti zitti zitti
mammamia marco takeshi's castle è così
difficile quando sbagli ostacoli e sales
arrivare fino a sto punto un test non so
neanche come ho fatto ma va bene lo sto
pianoforte non aiuta per niente lo dico
io porca vacca ce l'ho fatta no
attenzione che è pieno di bolle lì è
dove riuscire a centrare perché pino gli
occhi alle polle che sembra che è ma
[Musica]
io odio la mia vita per il governo non
ci posso credere
questo gioco fatto dall inferno
programmato all'inferno sto gioco come
faccio
non si può se l'ho fatto l'ho preso l'ho
preso sotto carlo toccati sono state
giocando bene bene bene bene bene tutto
tutto calcolato che per carità dove sto
gol sta la allora uno no ecco la testa
non ci arriva
forse c a riposarci possono prelevare
forze attenzione io ci credo ma di come
faccio devo fare una nuova propulsione
porco del demo e neanche guarda non c'è
neanche bisogno
ho bisogno di propulsione per saltare
sui cose da loggia arrivo però non so
come arrivarci senza esplodere o farmi
tagliare a metà invece
invece un cazzo ragazzi ce la faccio di
più quando non ho il corpo non so perché
ma poi però questo in questo punto
preciso non salta più non so per quale
motivo ci ho provato uguale e proprio
dire senza al corpo è più facile in quel
punto poi dopo non l'ha fatto ed è bello
che dopo manca ancora un pezzo che è
bello incasinato cioè non è neanche
questa qualcosa parte facile questa è la
parte facile ora devo fare tutto con
calma per arrivare lì e fermarmi perché
devo poi pensare a come correre anche se
non c'è solo un modo per che però va
bene ok ci provo guarda se non riesco ad
esso mollo tutto perché è impossibile
ok e qua devo lanciare le camere be nice
dopo 62 anni bene mamma mi era il primo
era il primo pensiamo di pensa agli
altri come sto bene come sta mesi va
bene siamo sul finale ragazzi select e
l'inferno soffrirai divertiti per grazie
ho paura di vedere questa roba da troppi
ove anche sangue
beh ottimo non ho capito ma va bene e
già non riesco a fare no vabbè non si
può fare
dov'è traguardo finale su date e quello
sta laggiù a noi ce n'è un altro ancora
più in fondo lo vedo non si può fare a
livello quello dico già non si può fare
non è una casa via sul primo ostacolo
ok ok ok a
non lo finirò mai ma c'è qualcuno che ha
fatto sta roba
ok ma fermi c'è qualcosa mi sfugge o ce
l'ha fatta
no ok adesso sì ma cerco l'intervista
accorti che tipo a un chilometro come
arrivo lì a devo salteranno ho capito è
impossibile lo stato su sti cosi madonna
ragazza ha avuto sì fatta per il cre di
bi ce l'ho fatta
non so neanche come da avere coraggio si
è fatta fenomeno mio dovere l'abbiamo è
venuto lì da per vinta giusta devo
tirare la testa e adesso non ho neanche
capito dove devo andare
una figura a devo rimbalzare sul
martello che si muove ha capito se sì
come se fosse facile da ok no
ah ok un disastro globale ma ci provo
certamente devo aspettare il martello
caridi lì per poi rimbalzarsi sopra per
poi prenderlo spinta perfetto ottima
mira a parigi e brown bear iscrivervi al
canale dai non è male non è massimino
gli iscritti non è male faccio vieni da
quando sono nato ottimo bravo paese
contro questa è questa la mia skill dove
devo dire signori l'impegno ampio fosse
cagate figura è ottimo per tornare qua è
già un disastro se figuriamoci non ci
sono arrivato per una mamma mia ragazza
è mai difficile è veramente difficile e
io che pensavo che quello fosse il
finale a che sciocco ok ed evo devo
cercare quando c'è ed è fatta
bellissimo no no no no no no no no
benissimo benissimo bene veramente li
prendi fiato
bravo mai avuto la prontezza di prendere
fiato ma rivoli non devo farmi sul palo
ok ma devo andare ma detta arrivo lì e
mi fermo
ok ho sbagliato e spaccati a just a
testa dicono che questi lancio che
adesso mi ricordo
[Musica]
ok non c'era altro modo quindi bo credo
era perché poi rispetto che comunque
faccio arrivare con la testa lì no ci
vuole il polo formo no non lo so ragazzi
posso provarci senza ma è veramente
difficile per that's ok ragazzi last
tentativo è niente ci si può provare ci
ho provato ho messo tutto ma il peccato
che avrei voluto vedere l'ultimo livello
come ma c'è l'ultimo di questa opzione
dell'ultimo livello nel senso l'ultimo
checkpoint vero o mi sento di essere
arrivato al limite ragazzo provato
veramente di tutto adesso ci riprova è
un altro politici ed hanno tarato tutto
per l'impossibile non ho idea di come si
possa fare sicuramente c'è il modo di
farlo ma non lo troverò io di sicuro
guarda arrivati qua uno potrebbe anche
pensare che si possa arrivare colpo non
ci si può arrivare lì proprio a lanciare
la testa e poi di fare un percorso di
testa cioè ma è una maledizione è
proprio brutto brutto ma ci siamo
riattivati dai riproduttiva volta giusto
perché sono qua in corsa massima è stato
al limite vedete ho saltato al limite è
proprio impossibile
sono comunque soddisfatto di aver
provato fino a di essere arrivato fino
qua e se queste sono molto soddisfatto i
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto questo
benedetto vediamo se riuscirò prima o
poi a fare anche questo livello però gli
altri
male sinceramente era un po po strani
prodi tema le cose mi piace a catherine
trascrizione e lasciatemi anche consigli
su come si potrebbe fare l'ultimo
livello perchè vi giuro non ho idea era
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bene ragazzi
[Musica]